Your writing is unclear because you're
afraid of sounding repetitive. So, you
vary your sentence structure. And I know
this because I've worked with dozens of
academics and professionals whose
writing needs to be crystal clear.
They're founders using a book to build a
personal brand, executives writing white
papers, and researchers applying for
funding or publication. They think that
they need to vary the beginnings of
their sentences because they don't want
to sound repetitive. And sadly, some of
my own viewers on this channel have
fallen for the same trap. So, in this
video, I'm going to give you the simple
strategy I use with pretty much
everything I write to ensure that my
message rings clear in the mind of my
reader by repeating key concepts without
sounding repetitive. And if you like
learning about this stuff, then hey, me
too. which is why I created Writer
Science, the free newsletter for writers
who care about their readers. Link is
down below the like button. All right.
So, to understand this strategy, you
need to understand how reading actually
works. Otherwise, it's not going to work
for you. And the best way to explain
this is to imagine whatever it is you're
writing about as a movie and then ask
yourself, who would I put on the movie
poster? Who's the star of this passage?
Whose story does it tell? So, let's
start with a few simple sentences. Mary
smashed John in the face with a pie.
John's face was smashed by the pie. The
pie was smashed into John's face by
Mary. The smashing of a pie into John's
face was carried out by Mary. So,
although each sentence deals with the
same entities, that's John, Mary, a pie,
and maybe even smashing, each one tells
a different story. So, if I give you a
sentence like Mary smashed John in the
face with a pie and then I asked you
whose story this sentence describes, I
think most people would agree that this
sentence is about Mary. If the sentence
were a movie, then Mary would be on the
movie poster because it tells a story
about her. But if I tell you that the
pie was smashed into John's face by
Mary, well, now we're telling a story
about the pie. What did the pie do? How
is the pie's day today? Readers
implicitly assume that a sentence tells
the story of whoever or whatever shows
up first. So, to see how you can apply
this insight to make your own writing
more clear, I'm going to show you a
short model passage. And fair warning,
it's pretty bad. But don't worry about
it because we're going to fix it after
this. And so, as I read it out to you,
why don't you try to diagnose what you
think is wrong with this passage? Some
sort of palace revolt or popular
revolution plagued seven of eight reigns
of the Romanov line after Peter the
Great. In 1722, achievement by merit was
made the basis of succession when the
principle of heredity was terminated by
Peter. This resulted in many Zars not
appointing a successor before dying,
including Peter. Ivan V 6th was less
than two months old when appointed by
Sarena Anna. But Elizabeth, daughter of
Peter the Great, defeated Anna and
ascended to the throne in 1741.
Succession not dependent upon authority
resulted in the Boyers regularly
disputing who was to become sovereign.
Male primogenature became the law in
1797 when Paul I codified the law of
succession, but conspirators strangled
him, one of whom was probably his son,
Alexander I. Most people would agree
that this passage is pretty hard to
read. But when you ask readers what's
wrong with it, you're not going to get
helpful advice. Readers will say things
like, "It's unclear. It's dense. It's
badly organized." But the thing about
this generic reader feedback is that it
tells you the way the text makes readers
feel, but it doesn't tell you what the
writer should do about it. Like, what is
it about the writing that makes the
reader feel this way? And how can we
shape the writing to give readers the
opposite experience? That is the
experience of clarity, understanding,
and flow. The primary thing that's wrong
with this passage is that it makes
readers feel like their attention is
being pulled in all these different
directions. So, they wind up feeling
like a spectator at a tennis match. The
focus keeps shifting back and forth
among these different participants.
That's because the reader's attention is
normally trained on whatever shows up
first at the start of the sentence. And
so whenever you're diagnosing an unclear
passage like this, it can be helpful to
underline the first seven or eight words
of every sentence or every clause up
until the verb. That's usually a pretty
good way of finding out what's gone
wrong with the sentence. And when we do
that, we can already get a glimpse of
what's gone wrong here. there's no
coherence among the elements that we've
underlined. Like if you look only at
those elements, it would be next to
impossible to predict what the passage
is about. So not only is there needless
variety at the start of these sentences,
but they're also so abstract. So if this
passage were like a movie, what would
you put on the movie poster? A palace
revolt. Achievement by merit. This?
Like, could you draw me a picture of
achievement by merit? It's all so
abstract. Yet, this passage has a clear
cast of characters. We've got Peter the
Great, Serena, Anna, Elizabeth, and many
other members of the Romanov family.
That's who this passage is about. The
passage is a story about these
characters. So, to help readers perceive
that focus, we want to move those
characters to the start of their
respective clauses. This helps readers
perceive a global structure. So, we're
going to use the start of the sentence,
which is the first seven or eight words
before the verb, including the subject
position and any opening phrases. When
the opening section of neighboring
sentences share a small set of concrete
characters, it gives readers a sense of
unity. It's like they can zoom out and
see the big picture, the shape in which
each of these sentences hangs together.
And so since this passage is about the
Romanovs, I think it would make sense to
move the Romanovs and Peter the Great to
the beginning of the sentence. And the
thing that's going to let us do that is
the passive voice. Now, the passive
voice is something that many writing
teachers tell students never to use. But
in this case, it's what's going to allow
us to move elements around the sentence.
So instead of Peter the great at the end
of the sentence we can say seven of
eight reigns after oh that would be of
the Romanov after Peter the great and so
the verb we have here is plagued the
revolution plagued seven of eight
reigns. So that in the passive voice is
going to be was plagued by and now we
can put these other elements some sort
of palace revolution
or popular revolution they were plagued
by that. So the passive voice is what
allows us to shift the information
around the sentence. We go from the
revolutions plagued the Romanovs to the
Romanovs were plagued by the
revolutions. And if you'll excuse my
writing here and just understand the
content, this revision works well. Not
only because it puts important
characters that are going to recur
throughout the piece upfront, but it
also saves the abstract information that
is a palace revolt or popular
revolution. It saves that abstract
information for the end of the sentence.
And readers read most easily when the
sentence begins with simple concrete
information and ends with more complex
abstract information. It just makes it
easier for readers to integrate. If you
give readers something concrete at the
start of the sentence that they can
easily grasp, then they can more easily
manage complexity later on in the
sentence. Now to sentence two. In 1722,
achievement by merit was made the basis
of succession when the principle of
heredity was terminated by Peter. And so
here we have the passive voice again,
but we are ending this sentence with a
familiar concrete entity that is Peter
who we've already mentioned. He's a
Romanov. So I think we definitely want
him to be at the start of this clause.
And looking ahead, since the next
sentence references this word successor,
we probably want to get this idea of
succession at the end of its clause so
that it leans forward into the next
sentence. So we have two clauses. That's
going to be
we want succession at the end. So that's
going to be the same sentence.
And as you might have noticed, I've
reversed the order of these clauses
because this is the cause and this is
the effect. So we want our sentences to
reflect the actual sequence of these
things. So we're going to begin with
Peter that links back to the previous
sentence with Peter here. And we want to
end this sentence with succession
because that's what's coming next. But
you know what? Since this second clause
is now the effect of this first clause,
then we can actually reduce it and
that'll make it a lot more compact. So
rather than was made the basis of
succession, we can move this verb
to the front of the clause and turn it
into a nonfinite ingchievement
by merit the basis of succession. And
that's a little bit handier because it
gives prominence in the sentence to this
first clause about Peter terminating the
principle of heredity. And then it makes
this secondary clause uh subordinate to
that first one. So it makes it a little
bit lighter and more compact and allows
us to focus on the cause and its effect.
Now, as mentioned, this next sentence
uses the word successor, which obviously
is not the same word, but it's the same
concept as the one that we ended on
here, succession. So to keep that same
old to new information flow, I think we
definitely want successor at the start
of this sentence and as well as Peter.
But right away, one thing I notice about
this sentence is this verb resulted in.
Whenever I see that, I know something
has gone wrong in the sentence. Verbs
should carry action. uh material
processes, things that are happening in
the world that are that are performed by
characters and that your reader can
picture in their mind. So, whenever we
see an empty verb like resulted in or uh
occurred, you know, something like that,
it's a weak verb. And so, what it tells
me is that the real action is probably
hiding somewhere else in the sentence.
It's probably buried away in a noun. So
let's first see if we can find that
action and restore it to the verb where
it belongs. And I suppose that action
must be a point. So let's see if we can
build the sentence around that verb a
point. And we know that we want
successors at the start of the sentence
so that it links back.
So in this case, it's not the successors
who did the appointing. They were
appointed. So again, we're going to use
the passive voice. They were not
appointed by many Zars
by many Zars before dying. And we can
capture this meaning of this resulted in
with a simple adverb consequently. How
about that? But now we have a new
problem because if you take a look, we
have just this string now of
prepositional phrases by many Zars
before dying. And it's also a bit of a
dangling modifier. I don't know if you
remember that from your grammar class,
but including Peter,
that should occur next to Zars, not
before dying. Like, it's a little bit
awkward to say. Consequently, many
successors were not appointed by many
Zars before dying, including Peter. Not
going to say it's wrong. Don't fight
with me about grammar in the comments,
but I'm saying it's a little bit
awkward. It's not ideal. And so, is
there a solution to this? Can we reduce
the number of prepositional phrases
here? And can we get Peter closer to the
category to which he belongs, which is
Zars? Well, my solution to this is to
repackage it all to take it out of these
prepositional phrases and to package it
into a noun phrase. So, by many Zars
before dying, how about we're not
appointed before the death of many Zars,
including Peter. So that's great because
we get to now end this passage with
reference to Peter and he's going to
come up next as will Zars and it lets us
f rather than having all these different
nouns in this prominent position we can
just have the one which is death and
that makes the sentence a lot more
compact. I always say noun phrases are
kind of like these uh suitcases. If you
can, if you have long sprawling
information, you can probably package it
all into a noun phrase, and that makes
things a little bit more nimble and
concise and easier to manage. Now, this
next passage is a bit of a doozy, but we
can resolve it by applying this same
strategy of strategic repetition. So it
says Ivan V 6 was less than 2 months old
when appointed by Serena Anna but
Elizabeth a daughter of Peter the great
defeated Anna and ascended to the throne
in 1741. So we have kind of two main
clauses here and those are separated by
but. So this is like the major division
in this sentence. And then on either
side of that but is two complex
sentences. We have Ivan was less than
two months old when he was appointed by
Serena Anna and Elizabeth defeated Anna
and ascended to the throne in 1741. So
I'm going to put that butt here just to
help us keep track of everything. And
then let's just apply this strategy of
strategic repetition. So we just
mentioned Zars at the end of the last
passage including Peter. So for sure we
want to get Zars Zena Anna right here to
the beginning. Zorena Anna. What did she
do when appointed by Serena Anna? So she
appointed
Ivan V 6th. When let's put this down
here when he was less than two months
old. And that's great because we now we
still have these uh familiar characters,
concrete characters linking back. He he
and Zarina is linking to the previous
sentence. But and then we have new
characters here. We have el well we have
Peter the Great and he's a little bit
familiar, but we have Al Elizabeth uh
his daughter and we have Anna. So
Elizabeth is the one who ascended and
Anna was the one who is defeated. So,
let's put Anna at the start of this next
clause. That would be Anna or I guess
that would be she because there's only
one female in the previous passage. So,
she was defeated
by Now, this is tricky because we have
Peter the Great. So, that is going to,
you know, we want to say she was
defeated by Elizabeth, daughter of Peter
the Great. But then that creates a new
problem because Elizabeth is the new
character and Peter the Great is the
familiar one. So we want Peter the Great
to come first here and Elizabeth to come
after because Elizabeth is going to be
the one who's in the subject position up
here. She's the one
she's the one who ascended to the
throne. So how do we resolve that? Well,
I think what we could do is write Peter
the Great's daughter, Elizabeth.
Just going to write Peter here. Peter's
daughter,
Elizabeth. And we don't want to say
Elizabeth. So, we'll just use a pronoun
who. And so that sentence becomes Serena
Anna appointed Ivan when he was less
than two months old comma but she was
defeated by Peter's daughter Elizabeth
who ascended to the throne in 1741.
Now an interesting thing happens with
this next sentence cuz when we look
ahead we see this concept of succession
appear. So here it is and then
succession is not in this passage and
then it is in this passage and of course
the previous one. So how do we help the
reader navigate this macro structure?
Like why did we lose succession here?
Well, we lost it because this this this
little story here about Ivan and Serena
Anna and all these people that was kind
of doubleclicking into this sentence.
So, it's an example. And so, I think it
would be really helpful to the reader if
we could flag that with a signpost,
right? Just by saying, for example. Now,
these transitional phrases, for example,
and however and things like that,
honestly, they can be overused in a lot
of writing, but this is the real
function of it. Like you should use
these transitional devices sparingly,
but whenever you use them, make sure
that it's for the purpose of helping
your reader navigate this macro
structure so that they don't get lost in
uh in the trees for the forest. In the
forest for the trees. How's that go? But
do you see my point? Like it's clear
writing is not simply a matter of
getting the reader to be able to
interpret each individual sentence. They
also need to see how all those sentences
hang together. And transitional phrases
like, for example, uh really helpful in
that regard. So, returning now to the
idea of succession. Succession not
dependent upon authority resulted in uh
uh uh there's that lousy empty verb
again. So, we know we're going to fix
that. It resulted in the boyers
regularly disputing who was to become
sovereign. And so right away whenever we
see a verb like that, we know that the
action is probably hiding out somewhere
in the sentence. So to fix it, we can
look at this sentence and just ask
ourself who does what? And whenever we
ask that question, we can easily see
that the characters here are the boyers.
And what are they doing? They are
disputing something. So we know that we
want to put the boyers over here in the
subject position. And we want to put
dispute in the verb. And what did they
dispute? They disputed
who was to become sovereign. And now
once again the relationship here is
cause and effect. Right? So this
succession not dependent upon authority
that caused the boyers to have this
effect. So we'll move that down here.
And now if we joined these two clauses
with a word like because
you know so if we wrote something like
because succession
did not depend upon authority. If we use
the connector because then it forces us
to put this uh succession at the end. So
the boyers is the new information and
succession is the old information. But
because is forcing us to do that. So if
we wanted to rearrange these clauses so
that boyers came at the end and
succession came at the beginning. Well
honestly you could again people can
fight with me in the comments about
this. You could use because for this
purpose I'm not going to say it's wrong.
Don't talk to me about grammar. But I
think it's better to use since.
Since has the same logical relationship
as because, but it communicates that
this clause is linking backwards to
something previously known. That's the
purpose of it. That's why it's there.
Why would the language have both because
and since? Languages never have two
words that mean exactly the same thing
and have the same function. So, I
believe that the word since exists to
allow us to set up a relationship of
cause and effect like this while still
being able to organize the way
information is laid out in the sentence.
All right, so second to last sentence,
we get the word succession again. And of
course, we want to get that to the start
of the sentence. So, let's read this
sentence together, then fix it. Male
primogenature became the law in 1797
when Paul I codified the law of
succession. All right. So just like
watermelon is a hyponym of fruit, male
primogenature is a hyponym of the law of
succession. They refer to the same
entity, the same concept. It's like the
law of succession is an umbrella over
male primogenature. So since we have
been arranging it so that succession
occurs at the start of the sentence, I'm
saying it's the same thing for male
primogenature. Even though those are
different words, they're referring to
the same concept. So for sure, we want
to get male primogenature at the start
of the sentence. And since the next
sentence, if we look ahead, uh contains
um it's it's about Paul the first, he
got strangled. So because this next
sentence is about Paul the first, we
want him to be at the end of the
sentence. So let's keep the start of
this sentence the same, which is that
male primo became the law of the land. I
just piece that away. That's handy. All
right. So let's keep the start of that
the same. And so since this second
clause begins with when it's quite nice
that this first clause ends with
reference that prepositional phrase that
references time in 1797. And so it
becomes male primo gener became the law
in 1797. When Paul the first codified
the law of succession when can I just
copy this? When copy paste a great when
the law of succession
was codified by Paul the first. Done and
dusted. Last sentence but conspirators
strangled him. One of whom was probably
his son Alexander I. So let's get him to
the start of the sentence. But he was
strangled
by conspirators. Don't make me write
that whole thing out. Copy paste by
conspirators, one of whom
was probably his son Alexander the
first. And so now we can marvel at our
hard work. But as I read this revised
passage to you, tell me, would you
describe it as boring, repetitive,
unclear, or is it clear and easy to
understand? Seven of eight reigns of the
Romanov line after Peter the Great were
plagued by some sort of palace revolt or
popular revolution. In 1722, Peter
terminated the principle of heredity,
making achievement by merit the basis of
succession. Consequently, successors
were not appointed before the death of
many Zars, including Peter. For example,
Serena Anna appointed Ivan V 6 when he
was less than two months old, but she
was defeated by Peter the Great's
daughter, Elizabeth, who ascended to the
throne in 1741.
Since succession did not depend on
authority, the Boyers disputed who is to
become sovereign. Male primogenature
became the law in 1797 when the law of
succession was codified by Paul I. But
he was strangled by conspirators, one of
whom was probably his son Alexander the
repetitive. Your writing becomes clear
when you begin sentences with old
familiar information. But clear writing
is not just about the words that you
write. It's also about the words that
you cut. So, watch this video next
because it's going to show you how to
cut the bloat from your pros and
compress your ideas in a way that puts
less cognitive load on your readers. So,
be sure to go check it out.